non ci credo
secondo episodio di tre colori di
pennarelli gialle a caso di diverso
marrone oltre i pennarelli al di
ammontare anche in iter quindi avremo
due cover di tenere di più un colore di
glitter e non vedo l'ora di vedere come
starà mica male ai di tutti cosi come
sempre dovrete per ogni turno votare se
vince a vita video o no per vitale
quindi ogni turno a scrivere se nei
commenti il turno numero 1 visualizza o
torna numero 2 ha vinto e vibrare in
base al disegno che vi piace di più in
base ai colori che ci sono come è stato
colorato è tutto qui parliamo accordo
che lasciate un bel live se volete
vedere un terzo episodio faccio coraggio
di un pezzo che 10.000 nice
iniziamo subito in a1 svegliamo il
nostro primo disegni da colorare 32 ora
no hai sbagliato dovevo tirare
ora ecco qua abbiamo lungo il logo di
bee suv che sapete benissimo che è non
ve lo dico scrivere che coloreto vedete
qua sopra o questo proprio a
disposizione 1 dic
dovrete mi dimetto ti diamo un'idea di
tutto perfino vale la coppa del mondo
dall'usi cambiassero colore allora chi
inizia cambia fuori successo che non gli
piace parte molto capace c'è però di
prendere molti complimenti prendere un
prota un viola quello che dovevo cercare
di essere creativa di video di arrone
mannaggia
vai che è un arancione molto chiara non
lo facciamo troppe stare bene attento
che ha detto kasami 6 cuore rosa rosa
rosa lilla che bello che se non c'entra
un cavo lino divieti grigio grigio
[Musica]
bruttino farei con la regione verde voci
troppo costoso ma ora è il turno dei
click permette di offerte no no mai più
avanti questo proprio focallo a estranei
sono sul posto per compreso il verde
comunque braille mente preservata books
e glitterato russia scrivi qualcosa di
carino qualcosa di carino
siamo pronti e sono scappati gli occhi
ma con gli occhi
[Musica]
ok
vai
spray con verde mozzo di troll verde e
arancione scaduto primo che finisce con
terrà fino a 10 e l'altra persona dovrà
finire di colorare entro dieci secondi
quindi non abbiamo tutto il tempo del
mondo vedi dobbiamo sbrigarci
[Musica]
prenotazione
allora vediamoli meglio vediamo lì da
vicino con il mio ho fatto il usato il
lilla e poi ho fatto delle macchioline
dei cerchietti marroncini immersi in
questo tipo avevo fatto il marrone avevo
fatto dei cerchietti villa monosi vedo
poi ho fatto tutti i glitter l'ho fatto
tutto nel cerchietto infatti è rimasto
un po in là del colore
dico di più quindi questa è la mia
creazione anche se un po incasinato
potato vediamo quella di vitale allora
spiega si è praticamente rimasto più
fedele al mio solo in faccia il
bardolino bertolino fosforescente che
sarebbero giallo e lo so ma è questo qui
in realtà verdolino fosforescente poi lo
sfondo marroncino più o meno come quello
di youtube e poi l'intero verde è stato
bravo a riuscire a mettere i glitter e
tutti nella scritta adesso l'attore
secondo me sono fortissimi portato a
mettere in quelli che investì
direttamente tutti a terra perché non è
facile mettere tutti attorno
diciamo che ho visto da lontano sono
bellissimi ho visto da vicino 20 ma
allora votate nei commenti torna numero
1 vince a vita o vitale
pronti alla rivelazione per 3 2 1 o meno
male di crisi abbiamo le mozzicone gli
occhietti a pollicino che sarebbe le
voci che io non so più spesso
praticamente non innamorata che lavora
da diversi
facciamo tutto colore corretti ma tonino
rosa ho visto forse lo bene per i
pollicini umbro che fortuna
[Musica]
[Risate]
gente a notte di prendere col a darci
piatto però l'avvocato dai un bel colore
è che forse un auto blu e azzurro scuro
cappello più veloce tale ritardo abbiamo
visto peschiamo adesso va bene
chiudi gli occhi ma bari io lo so che il
comune vuole evitare il colore preferito
quello che hai addosso io non c ero io
quello che fa casino dai come la pesca
[Musica]
festa o brutto brutto brutto
siamo fra 0 e 2 1 buffon mi fa capire da
solo è diverso almeno hit list ma è
l'analisi del 3 1
allora prime seclì persone negli occhi
se messi in tutta la fame che hanno gli
occhi innamorati
andiamo a vedere il pieno vicino allora
io stavo provando a mettere twitter solo
nella faccia e veniva dal mondo
meritando gli occhi alla bob però poi
non sono riuscito perché basato tutto
quindi ho detto io li metto vento non è
che ha sballato disegno seduti a spalla
che non segna mai fatto gli occhi li ho
fatti di due colori verdi e blu è la
bocca e verte quindi questa rabbia voci
su per un look vediamo quello di vitale
devo dire che molto cari a questo mi
piace un sacco il fatto che gli occhi a
forma di cuore siano gli jonici svizzera
il periodo molto provo a rimanere dentro
i buoi io sono qui sono capace della
colorata fai clic per accomunare
che assomiglia molto bassi nei 100
bottiglie vuote alla vita o d'italia è
stata vista questo prepara una piccolina
signora terra sarà una rivoluzione due
strani diamo charlie tahan carriera
quando già il giorno sì e non vedo l'ora
di vederlo di qualche colore di
parcheggiare i sardi chi pone mo di
colori diversi via sono un fatto che tu
non sai d'acqua invece di fuoco giallo
che tipo elettro più viva che mai
[Applauso]
arancione di patteggiare
e allora potrebbe uscir di un posto
miglia prevedeva attiva
ciao ciao giallo carrelli la prova e ci
può stare corti vai celeste celeste
chissà con cena lo sai che mondo poco ma
secondo me si può fare si che chi vuoi
ancora non è buffa si aspetta mai questa
ciao argentato argento pertanto sarà
ancora più shiny con l'argentina a
quelle murray non so perché perché sì ci
sta bene perché mi imposi in mente
alcune quale dell unione presto questo
giallo pensavo che può utilizzarlo ma in
realtà è d'urso
pronto quindi è rotto e gli attesi nei
commenti che altri disegni mettere nelle
prossime palenque quindi cos'altro
fulvia basta ma qualche personaggio ma
sorta di 32
[Musica]
anche il tuo già restart elettro e mezzo
e un centro fiammate allora ve li
facciamo vedere più da vicino e poi
dovete votare chi vince il mio zar
izzard electro l'esperto mi piace
tantissimo gli ho anche fatto una
saletta che esce dalla prima chiama è
anche una fetta come voi mi è piaciuto
ecco che ci siano i glitter
brillantinati nella pancia e nell'ala ed
è tutto giallo con la fiammetta rosa mi
piace un sacco che sfocia ritardo di
tipo elettro vediamo così acido molto
bene questo è il mio invece è
ufficializzata di fuoco banca di
ghiaccio perché c'è anche non solo il
fuoco qua dietro con il clipper tutto
acceso ma c'è anche le vele
e anche di ghiaccio non si puo vedere
qui vedete è terzo con arrabbiato ma c'è
il glitter rosa niente quindi vuol dire
rinunciare mai usato come lo era già
richard buono questo qui non siamo a
casa una corda e iniziata questa il mio
quindi ho suonato edilizia indebitare
per il terzo round aveva già fatto
vedere vitale allora ho detto terzo
round in realtà è quarto e ultimo round
abbiamo la nostra monster prize unicorno
e questo sì da super carino perché ha un
sacco di dettagli sarà super difficili
da fare siccome questa tantissimi
dettagli abbiamo deciso di prendere tre
colori più glitterato cena la sua lola
azzurro è stato piace
[Applauso]
ma anche se marrone per un po più chiaro
marroncino perché a me basta un esordio
arancione dai composto dai celestino
quindi a influire un cestino
va bene che colore è il mio genere scuri
celeste scuro vai a coloro che si può
fare un coccolone vuoi dato io e io
vorrei tanto dire io adesso non so dove
iniziare sbagliato vento forte o
cliccato con lamentati per strizzare
è lo stesso che la sta cavando
abbastanza bene dai ragazzi abbiamo
fatto ci abbiamo messo un sacco è
altissimo colorata perché piena di
dettagli stati rotti 32 ora sono tutte
bellissime la mia scura scura bellissima
risaltano gli occhi tutti i colori ma
anche la tua celeste carini si va a dio
vederle da vicino tutta la mia lol
mi piace tanti simon vorrei che corona
originale fosse così perché è bellissima
perché singolare 6 arancione questi
oggetti mobili e di lasciarli bianche
così fanno il contrasto con la pelle
scura il vestitino arancione glitterato
le scarpe glitterate ragazza dalle loro
parti di uo tra le prove che abbiamo
fatto queste quella che vi piace di più
se vediamo la tua ammirato molto carina
mi piace che ci sia così tanto la mia e
pallidi rapallin era però già tutti lì
pronta ad l'iter per fare la pesci poi
li ho fatti capelli celesti di due
tonalità che non si vedono con gli
elastici colorati ips6 sortite di
chiavari e che non ci credo che
dimenticati poi gli ho fatto tutta la
coroncina di fiori non ritorno le mèches
quindi ho fatto le meches bionde che ben
il regista viso di spirato a te che gli
ho fatto il vestitino bicolor con le
cerniere emigrati difficile poi si
diceva dalla gonna frise ma non nego i
free se eletti questo è l'ultimo quindi
votate chi vince testavano difficile da
votare forti e sono tutte e due belli
dove però votate divise anita o male
allora ecco quanto si quelli che ho
fatto io scriveteli commenti quale mi è
piaciuto di più fra questi quattro a me
quello che è piaciuto di più e ha
riferito la londinese motorizzate letto
così invece perché sono quelli di vitali
e allora tutte di più il primo il
secondo via tanto carino si nota
guardando poi ci abbiamo il terzo che
c'ha rezart di fuoco e di ghiaccio e in
ultimo la nonna quality piaciute di più
a te allora tra i miei quello che mi è
piaciuto di più è stata sicuramente la
nonna dove mi sono impegnato di più
lei è carina ma anche uno smile shot è
un bel mai scontate ora vi lasciamo 4
cartolinesco cliccare per vedere la
challenge precedente divertendo altre
challenge disegno giochi divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite
posizione